hi guys what's up oh you're gonna talk
to you we are you can wait when I say hi
no I'll just be like hi guys we are back
it is ven seven months since you've last
seen us and we've been really busy
really busy we have built a kitchen in
the diamond cab with the frigid dater
yes and we have an outdoor shower for it
a hippy outdoor show we built a wood
fire hot tub in a trough for animals to
drink after we have the hump out it
looks like origami
it's crazy looking and we built a
wardrobe cabin you like to call it a
storage cabin but no I like to call it
Sarah's closet yeah it actually looks
like an angry bird so that's what I was
going to say when I was in it it does so
what some of you have seen and what some
of you should go check out is that about
a year ago we bought this property it
had some really creepy cabins on them
I'm actually genuinely scared right now
knock on the door maybe someones
[Music]
we tour them all down this is the best
day ever
[Applause]
we stuffed them in a dumpster or ten
dumpsters and I'm trying not to ramble
and then we built this amazing diamond
cabin
[Music]
for those of you who aren't familiar
with where we're at Sarah and I bought a
property here in the temperate
rainforests of the Pacific Northwest it
gets like a hundred and forty two inches
of rain a year
this is not your SpiderMonkey rainforest
this is your kind of chilly but moss
dripping rainforest the most beautiful
area ever word a temperate rainforest
right next to the coast and we have the
Olympic Mountains backed up against us
it's insane that's where we bought this
property and that's where we're building
cabin land basically a fantasy Fun Zone
of cabins and joy
[Music]
on this season of cabin land you're
gonna see us build a real house but it's
not like any old house it is three
cabins connected by floating hallways
we're gonna get to that soon but before
we do let's catch you up on all the
other things this is like cribs cabin
land yeah so we're locking up right now
on the diamond cabin which is what we
built last season the very first
structure at cabin land hello hello
welcome to our humble abode aka the
diamond cabin our little 90 square feet
of Heaven home we have here we have our
kitchen we have jacob's chair we have my
loveseat that I sit in every day and we
have the loft upstairs originally all we
had was a chair a fireplace and a couch
in there we have added a kitchen that's
the most consequential thing that has
happened we lost zero floor space those
walls were brilliant did you plan that
wait did you get that where you tell me
where they recording it's an accident
and if I were a real man I'd pretend
like it was intentional I meant to you
that and if you'll remember back to
season one Sarah was very critical let's
put it here
and then let's go inside what's his
smile this is smaller than I thought it
was gonna be she did it oh that's the
word thank you oh my gosh looking for
we're gonna bizarro word world she's my
she's giving me the tier 3 vocabulary so
yeah she was a little critical if you
remember season 1 she was like laughing
at me
couch chair table bed of mocking me but
it's okay it worked out because of the
crazy design of the walls kind of
shooting from the outside outward we
take up very little floor space to get
this huge countertop back it up let's
see cuz this is huge
alright for a tiny cabin this is the
kitchen what's so awesome is that we get
all of this countertop space from my
plants for the pies that Sara's mom
makes us for the sink the sink that's
filled with dirty dishes in the worst
behind the oatmeal Sara and our hot
plate and our cabinets and you could
check out my drawer down here it's
stuffed shotgun shells and band-aids and
we got a little frigid nighter all of
this space takes up like zero floor
space we actually get 37 square feet of
countertop space for sacrificing two and
a half feet of floor space down here
look right here look it's little you
need this anyway this little bit right
here it's like nothing this is our cabin
kitchen the diamond cabin kitchen on to
the next one another great addition to
the diamond cabin was the outdoor shower
we got all these mushrooms in our shower
we got ferns in our shower normally
people wouldn't brag about those things
here at cabin land we strive for that it
just blends right in with nature it's
such a magical experience shower
[Music]
and even though it's cold being in the
trees with water dripping off the moss
the birds chirping don't forget to tell
them about the steam it's so good in the
woods you got steam through the forest
you got that filtered light and we use a
little hot water heater that's made for
washing horses and other animals and
barnyard animals but it's perfect for us
and we're about as filthy so
and then what away cut so then what was
the other one that we did so we built my
personal favorite is the wood fire hot
tub what we already had to work with was
a Shack back there that we tore down in
the beginning and we left its old
chimney stack so we hooked the wood fire
hot tub
up to that and it's totally functional
again and I've missed bath so much it's
so nice having late nights with wine and
talking and flirting and the wood fire
hot tub cooking in our little horse
trough
the hot tub makes her flirt I like that
don't forget boys hot tub makes her
flirt but not the kind that you're
thinking this one takes like 2 or 3
hours to get to heat hot cold therapy
get in a hot tub ice-cold water
feels good it's really hot but once
you're out there under the stars or the
forests pretty gorgeous it's awesome the
hippie hot tub brought to you by cabin
light okay so we just drove to this side
of the property to show you the other
two structures we've built this is the
truck cabin by the way and we'll totally
do an episode on that if you want but
this is the pump house
this is the house the little cabin that
we built to hold all of the filtration
system for the water that we get out of
the well this was his first non
asymmetrical structure we want to build
a cabin that looked different from all
different perspectives instead of what
we've built before which are these
symmetrical cabins depending on where
you're standing it has a different look
to it and this door right here is
actually Jacob Woodling signature
there's a signature door right here and
what's cool about it is if you come over
here and then you go over like this and
you look at it you can see there's like
shiny wood like this in these two
quadrants and then you move this way you
got shiny wood like that does the camera
set up so you can see it too so that's
one thing that we love about that was
totally unintentional by the way I was
like this is the theme today yes I did
all right
I did no now inside here let's take you
in here here's our our filtration system
okay so we've got like a lot of water
but it's not that good until we put it
through all of this filtration we
learned a lot on this cabin because this
cabin actually gets a lot of direct Sun
and we love putting moss on the roof but
what we noticed is that it started to
kind of like bake out the moss no matter
how much we watered it so we were kind
of worried about killing all of the moss
we realized it needed a little bit of
shade so what did Sara suggest well I
was curious if grass would grow on the
moss so we did a little experiment and
look and the let the mosses all come
back to life genius that's why I married
a genius so yeah this is our thing this
is our lay on so good we can climb up
smell it serious know it what's your
favorite angle by the
because every angle looks different I
like this angle the best because it kind
of looks like a ski jump I want to show
you my favorite angle because I like
seeing the windows because it's very
house looking windows this is my
absolute favorite okay see both windows
yeah yeah yeah what do you guys think
which side is better
yeah I'd say my side is better but
whatever no look at that big old field
grass I'd never mow this one more good
angle over here this looks like a face
to little eyeballs every angle is so
different having gone
one more structure on the property to
show you let's go to the wardrobe cabin
the my cabin
it's this way the Wardrobe cabin
wardrobe cabin this is the last cabin on
our tour sorry it's getting late it's
getting dark it's actually starting to
rain but this is it this is what we've
created to store all of Sara's outfits
and honestly I have a lot of skinny
jeans and this is where we store we keep
it nice and dry inside and nice and
toasty warm but again it looks really
different from every angle this is the
Angry Bird one yes this is the Angry
Bird angle right here see this is like a
pissed-off
little nose right station goals are from
an old shack that was also on the
property we're gonna start though with
salvaging all these shingles off here
even these wet ones I just have so much
life and I'm still her mom and her
stepdad really helped out with I mean
it's a lot of work care and all these
cabins up but you can't buy this stuff
gold mine
it looks like it's been sitting here for
like a hundred years and then also
Jacobs door this was all Jacobs idea but
I will say that I was the one that
pushed him to not do the traditional
Jacob wit sling dance so we took this
one piece and we kind of made these
little pete trim pieces to match it
Ranger
oh yeah the camera guy goes so our two
camera guys one of them who's filming
this right now Trevor this is a dog
Ranger skateboarding dog let's go inside
and right here is my walk-in closet
uh-huh thank you for owning it this is
the Wardrobe cabin this is where we keep
all of our stuff that needs to stay
stabilized and dry before this
everything was in bins so difficult to
find our stuff also it was most the
times wet and starting to get moldy just
a dankness so let's take the tour do we
have our jacket oh my gosh I got
somewhere to finally have a full-length
mirror this was so nice and I also like
to look in the full-length mirror just
because I like to see my skinny jeans
it's been a while so we also have all of
our stuff that hangs which is cool this
is Jacob section this is my section
right here which is every shirt that I
had as a teacher and the ties to go with
it and this is just a moderate small
that's all yours
behind you is in there is all mine
that's all yours this is all these
blankets are both of ours yeah so we
have some common space too
I love the ceiling detail the new cabin
the main cabin is actually gonna have a
very similar detail so it's a cool place
to practice that out and yeah I mean we
just put we kept this simple I mean it
is just a storage shed or closet so it's
just plywood on the walls but we did
trim it out and yeah yeah we love this
place all right so thank you for taking
the tour of our cabin land this is cabin
land cribs edition
now we gotta go make the model for the
new cabin let's get back to work
yeah
we're going to show you today building
the model of the cabin the cabin that
we're gonna live in that we're gonna be
building all season long it's d'études
we've been going all day non-stop but
it's starting to come together
[Music]